Les réunions chez W9 :
Les mecs, on a perdu les droits de diffusion pour Les Simpson !
Non, je déconne !
Je déconne !
Non, je déconne pas !
Chez LUCASFILM :
Non, non, il y a six Star Wars, il n'y aura pas de septième film.
Il y aura un septième film, je viens d'avoir l'idée.
Il y aura même une trilogie !
Allez, hop, j'appelle *Gégé* et puis comme ça on s'arrange bien parce que je...
Chez M6 :
On diffuse quoi ce soir ?
Top Chef ! - Ouais.
Top Chef : l'after ! - Ouais.
Top Chef : que sont-ils devenus ? - Ouais
Top Chef : Jean et Norbert, le Défi ! - Ouais.
Chez APPLE :
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour l'iPhone 6 ?
On améliore la batterie ?
On peut faire la reconnaissance digitale, mais derrière le téléphone...
C'est très bien, ça !
Ou la batterie, on pourrait la...
Ou attends, attends, on peut faire un écran 3D, sinon !
Ah, ouais, un écran 3D ! C'est très bien, ça.
Ou la batterie ?
Oh, il cuit des œufs ! - Il cuit des œufs !
Chez M6 :
Et : Top Chef et les gendarmettes. - Ouais.
Et l'année prochaine ?
Alors, pour l'année prochaine, j'avais pensé à : Pékin Express ! - Ouais.
Pékin Express :  L'after ! - Ouais.
Pékin Express : Norbert et Jean, le Défi ! Ouais.
Chez les ANONYMOUS :
La réunion peut commencer... C'est quoi ce bordel, là ?
Qu... Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Attends, non, quoi, qu'est-ce qu'il y a ? Qu... Quoi ? Quoi ?
C'est quoi ce masque, là ?
Quel... mais on m'a dit : « Prends un masque. », moi, je prends un masque !
On s'était mis d'accord sur le masque !
Oui, on avait envoyé...
Salut, les mecs !
D'accord, on a peut-être pas envoyé le bon mail, en fait...
Ah, voilà !
Chez SAMSUNG :
Ça, c'est le Galaxy S5 !
Oh ! Galaxy Note !
Oh, plus grand ! - Eh oui !
Oui, allo ? En fait, non, désolé. Oui, je sais, ouais !
Chez les ANONYMOUS :
Nous allons vous pirater, signé : Dany Boon !
Mais, non ! Mais, non ! Non !
Mais c'était dit dans le mail !
Mais y a pas eu de mail, y a pas eu de mail !
Chez HADOPI :
J'avoue avoir piraté toute une saison de Derrick...
Vous allez recevoir une lettre !
Oh, non, pas une lettre !
Si, une lettre !
Non ! Ah !
Chez DISNEYLAND :
Il faut optimiser les entrées au parc.
Une nouvelle campagne de pub, peut-être ?
C'est bien, une nouvelle campagne de...
(Musique de Disneyland)
Qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
Chez NINTENDO :
Elle se vend bien, la Wii U ?
La Wii ? Ouais, ouais, elle a cartonné !
Non, la Wii U, notre nouvelle console avec la lettre U à la fin...
Mais la lettre U n'existe pas !
Ici, je ne vois aucun document qui mentionne la Wii U... (Bruits de flamme)
(Rires)
Chez PLAYSTATION :
Comment elle bide la Wii U ! (Rires)
Elle marche bien, la PS Vita ?"Rires"
(Bruits d'allumettes et de flamme)
Chez SONY MUSIC :
Les mecs, on a retrouvé un enregistrement de Michael Jackson !
« Penser à acheter du lait. »
Non , mais c'est une liste de courses, ça...
Penser à acheter du lait... nyah, wooh !
Ah, c'est génial, ça ! On en fait en album !
Chez SPOTIFY :
Bonjour, enchanté...
Je vous présente Jean-Louis qui vient de chez Deezer, il va faire l'électricité ici.
Mouais, d'ailleurs, il va falloir me changer le spot là, le spot là, le spot "ify"..
(Jungle)
Je vous raccompagne pas, hein ? - Non, je connais le chemin...
Allez, va crever ! - Salut !
Chez SONY MUSIC :
CHANSON : « Penser à acheter du lait. »
Tu peux me faire un truc sur les tomates cerises ?
Ouais, ouais, c'est faisable, c'est faisable, c'est faisable !
Penser à acheter... nyah ! des tomates cerises, wooh !
Oh, mais, oui !
Chez FACEBOOK :
On va mettre de la pub là... et là...
... et là, là, là...
... là, là, là...
Chez McDO :
Alors, ça, c'est une photo du nouveau Big Mac...
Non, mais, attends, il est beaucoup trop beau. C'est pas du tout ce qu'on vend !
Non, on s'en fout, c'est la même chose !
Et ça, bah, ça c'est un photo de ma femme, mais qu'est-ce que ça fout là ?
Elle est très belle !
Ah bah tiens, la voilà, justement !
Ah, salut mon amour !
(Cris horrifiés)
Elle est belle, hein ?!
Chez FACEBOOK :
Mr. Zuckerberg, vous avez vraiment racheté l'Oculus pour deux milliards ?
Bah, ouais...
Euh, il faudrait racheter du papier, là, pour la photocopieuse.
C'est quatre milliards !
Bah ça reste du papier, quand même, hein...
Cinq milliards !
Chez DISNEYLAND :
CHANSONNETTE : ... la, la, lalala, la...
Ça reste dans la tête, hein?
Chez SONY PICTURES :
C'est l'histoire de Peter Parker qui se fait mordre par une araignée, du coup il développe...
Non, mais attends, attends, c'est Spider-Man, ça ?!
On a déjà fait trois films sur Spider Man !
Ah, non, pas du tout ! C'est... The Amazing Spider Man !
Ah, oui, oui ! Ah, oui, oui !
Ça va être un super film !
Un max de tunes !
Je vais pouvoir m'acheter un yacht
Chez ALLOCINE :
Vous avez vu, Michel , dans la séquence d'avant, il y a une perche dans le champ.
Ouais, bien vu, Michel !
Les mecs, vous avez pas vu Michel ?
Non, il est en vacances !
Ah, purée... - Salut, Michel.
Chez WAT :
Elle est pas mal, ta vidéo !
Non, c'est la pub...
Ah...
Chez DAILYMOTION :
Elle a fait 200 vues !
Oh, le BUZZ ! Ohh!
Chez TINDER :
Nope, nope, like !
Vous êtes embauchée !
Vous êtes la nouvelle assistante en aide commerciale.
Nope, nope, like !
Vous êtes mon assistant.
Bah, du coup, on couche ensemble ?
Ouais !
Ah, champagne !
Chez VINE :
On va commencer !
Comment booster les inscriptions ?!
Campagne de pub !
Ah, ça, jamais !
Un accord, sur Twitter ?
Excellente idée !
On a bien bossé !
À lundi !
Champagne !
Chez FLAPPYBIRD :
50 millions de téléchargements !
Super, on supprime ?
EVIDEMMENT !
Champagne !
Chez CHAMPAGNE :
Channnnnn...
Chez VOUS :
Pff, ils vont encore dire « champagne »...
Ouais, je préfère la première vidéo.
Chez MOI :
On va pas terminer tous nos gags par champagne !-Ouais.
"Bruit de verre brisé"CHAMPAGNE !
Chez FREE :
Oh les mecs !
Concernant Youtube...
Chez WAT :
Ah, non, encore une pub...
Chez SNAPCHAT :
Une petite vidéo, et...
Euh, non, Instagram !
Mais qu'est-ce t'as fait ?
Mais non, mais non ! Supprimer !
Che... Guevara...
En réunion...
à la Réunion :
Et... chez DISNEYLAND :
CHANSONNETTE : ... la, la, lalala, la... !
Abonne-toi !